[Music]
welcome to another episode of i got a
question i'm mikey and i'm going to be
addressing this question right here
i hear a lot about the mark of the beast
being a device predictive programming or
5g mind control what do you think the
mark is and will we be tricked or
coerced into getting it how can we be
saved or protected from it that's a
really good question can you be tricked
into taking the mark of the beast i
don't think so and you're gonna find out
why what is the mark of the beast line
upon line in the bible let's study it
out
revelation 13 16 says
and he causeth all both small and great
rich and poor free and bond to receive a
mark
in their right hand or on their forehead
so we know that we're looking at a mark
that's going to be on people's forehead
or in their hand let's look at another
verse revelation 14 9-10 says if any man
worship the beast and his image and
receive his mark in his forehead or in
his hand
the same shall drink of the wine of the
wrath of god so now we see a new word in
here that talks about worship we know
that the mark of the beast that you take
in your hand or in your forehead is
gonna have something to do with worship
remember that revelation 24 says
i saw the souls of them that were
beheaded for the witness of jesus and
for the word of god and which had not
worshipped the beast neither his image
neither had received his mark upon their
forehead or in their hands again we see
this about worship this mark has
something to do with worship remember
that as we're going to walk through
these scriptures here we go
matthew 15 3 8-9 says but he answered
and said unto them why do ye transgress
the commandment of god by your tradition
this people draweth nigh unto me with
their mouth and honor me with their lips
but their heart is far from me but in
vain do they worship me
teaching for doctrines the commandments
of men look at this jesus is talking
about doing away with his commandments
keeping traditions and he says their
worship is in vain
so these are people who worship him they
claim to worship him with their lips but
they don't show it with their actions
their heart is far from him luke 6 46
says and why call ye me lord lord and do
not the things which i say see jesus
talks about in the last days there's
going to be people that say lord lord we
did all these things in your name and he
says depart from me ye workers of
lawlessness or iniquity see their
actions weren't showing that they really
loved christ or followed him john 14 15
says if ye love me
keep my commandments jesus says you'll
know them by their fruits not because we
claim to be a christian or because we
carry a bible or go to church but
because of our actions you'll know them
by their fruits
so in the new testament when we're
talking about the mark of the beast it's
actually the greek word charagma but in
the old testament let's see if we can
find a parallel exodus 13 9 says and it
shall be for a sign or a mark unto the
upon thine hand and for a memorial
between the eyes or in the forehead that
the lord's law may be in thy mouth for
with a strong hand hath the lord brought
thee out of egypt so see in the old
testament there's a parallel to the mark
of the beast but this is the sign of god
and it's the same word mark it's h226
the hebrew word off and you're going to
take it in your hand or in your forehead
so when the religious pharisees would
read these scriptures they would take it
literally and they'd start tying boxes
of scripture to their head and on their
hand but what did jesus always say to
them that they were breaking his
commandments by keeping their own
tradition they were turning god's law
into some legalistic checkbox here again
we see in deuteronomy 6 5-8 it says and
thou shalt love the lord thy god with
all thy heart and with all thy soul and
with all thy might and these words which
i command thee this day shall be in
thine heart that's the commandments he's
going to write the commandments on our
heart right it continues and thou shalt
teach them diligently unto thy children
and thou shalt talk of them when thou
sittest in thy house and when thou
walkest by the way and when thou liest
down and when thou rise us up and thou
shalt bind them for a sign or mark upon
thine hand and they shall be as
frontlets between thy eyes
we see this repeated over and over
there's a third scripture that says the
same thing
deuteronomy 11 18 says therefore shall
ye lay up these my words in your heart
the commandments and in your soul and
bind them for a sign or mark upon thine
hand that they may be as frontlets
between your eyes
what is this really talking about if the
pharisees made this some legalistic
check box what was god really trying to
teach us a spiritual lesson that we
should keep his commandments in our mind
and the beliefs of our mind between our
eyes and by the obedient actions of our
hands
revelation 14 12 says here is the
patience of the saints here are they
that keep the commandments of god
and have the faith of jesus so this is
the description of god's last day people
who satan is going after but these are
the ones who overcome the mark of the
beast they're the ones that keep the
commandments of god
revelation 22 14 says blessed are they
that do his commandments that they may
have right to the tree of life and may
enter in through the gates into the city
here it is again that those who are
blessed are the ones who are keeping his
commandments they have right to the tree
of life and enter into the heavenly city
revelation 12 17 says and the dragon
which is satan was wroth or angry with
the woman and went to make war with the
remnant of her seed which keep the
commandments of god and have the
testimony of jesus christ when i see
this commandments of god and testimony i
see a parallel to isaiah 8 16 that says
bind up the testimony
seal the law among my disciples so
notice now that this testimony and this
law or commandments is a seal
in the last days there's going to be
people who are sealed by the holy spirit
and are the ones who overcome the mark
of the beast you're either going to have
the mark of the beast or you're going to
have the seal of god in your forehead
revelation 7 3 says saying hurt not the
earth neither the sea nor the trees till
we have sealed the servants of our god
in their foreheads this is a seal in our
mind the holy spirit indwelling in us
leading us into truth
empowering us to obey god ephesians 4 30
says and grieve not the holy spirit of
god whereby ye are sealed unto the day
of redemption so we see that the holy
spirit is the seal but what does the
holy spirit do
ezekiel 36 27 says
and i will put my spirit within you and
cause you to walk in my statutes and ye
shall keep my judgments and do them see
the holy spirit is the one who indwells
in us who can help us to obey god we
can't do it in our own strength it's
only because of the power of the holy
spirit and that is what seals us
ecclesiastes 9 10 says whatsoever thy
hand findeth the dew
do it with thy might for there is no
work nor device nor knowledge nor wisdom
in the grave whether thou goest so this
is talking about the hand doing works or
obeying god
and hebrews 10 16 says
this is the covenant that i will make
with them after those days saith the
lord i will put my laws into their
hearts and in their minds i will write
them see god wants us to keep his
commandments he wants us to think on
them he wants them to be in our minds
but also in our hearts because the
ultimate motive for obeying god is not
some legalistic checkbox it's because we
love god and when we love god our
desires will become his desires not my
will but your will be done revelation
describes two women and this is symbolic
of the body of christ these churches
there's a pure one who's doing the right
thing keeping the commandments of god
and there's the false one that's uh kind
of this lukewarm one world religion
system judges 2 17 says they went a
whoring after other gods and bowed
themselves unto them they turned quickly
out of the way which their fathers
walked in obeying the commandments of
the lord but they did not sow
so this symbolic imagery of the pure
white woman and the of babylon is
a representation of us are you going to
be a part of that pure white woman or go
a whoring after strange gods and
commandments of men the choice is yours
and it's not going to be something that
we can be tricked into we're not going
to be pinned to the ground and a
microchip jammed into your arm against
your will that damns you to hell this is
a freewill choice
i hope that answered your question keep
sending those questions in we love
getting to interact this way and we will
see you guys next time on i've got a
question
[Music]
so
you